my friends is starring in a massive HBO
show I'm desperate to find out the
ending how can I break her down I draw
Peter Som smirnoff ice and should tie
everything welcome back to gamma we are
joined by Suzanne and Mabel
okay the world's best agony yarns you're
gonna educate me in the art of being new
with a series of scenarios inspired by
game of frames are you ready to get your
best agony on arm so the first question
is one of my pals has become a bit of a
backstabber she's spilling at the poison
yes she is and trying to tip the power
in her favor not a nice girl how shall I
take her down you show your strength
when you let her have that power and
then you gain powerful doing yes yes no
physical violence over here
my boyfriend's become a white Walker
okay he's ghosting me how do I win him
back or should I even bother boy bye
he's a white Walker he's just cold and
you are hot honey Tammy
I'm grafting to get myself a husband and
a crown I won't go yeah we all are
Meghan we're coming for your man how do
I bloom on the first day is Mondays food
casual far too casual definitely oh I
would say that for third but that's
sorry
maples a bit loose today so control
she's really feeling up for PT show I'm
going to wet wedding that's very hard to
say and I want to slay the competition
with my dance moves what do you reckon
Paul with worm straight into backwards
well yeah
okay I want to go for Dothraki on my
body what does the ultimate workout
regime you would recommend you have to
really do some weightless yeah and lift
a lot really your heavy heavy thing
tires flip them yeah so close so more
than like the kind of eight beams
basically far more than double a go to
like hands and then maybe like a bag of
flour yeah baby steps baby steps around
the cake show okay
winter is coming yes it is girls and my
wardrobe is a touch tragic how could I
live another dog which is to reveal and
conceal these nipples would not hold up
winter in there there's no maybe just
use some color because often in winter a
lot people like what black gray and all
these sad colors and I really think it's
very important for you just briefs it up
with a pop of color color I just started
seeing someone who has a little finger
if you know what I mean oh it's not what
you have it's how you use it that's very
true
yes as may see nice in the show she has
a very thin Saul sword no needle but
damaged if I'm quick enough yeah now
guys I feel empowered a F after that I
feel like I've moved into mostly before
your actual I love you thanks so much
[Music]